The answer lies in understanding covariance.
Covariance only examines linear relationships and
is at the heart of linear regression.
A relationship which is not linear will have a very low covariance score.
Let's look at an example.
Let's look at y equals x squared between negative 1 and 1.
So y is totally determined by the value of x in this example.
Y and x have a very strong relationship.
Now, let's suppose that I were to sample points from
this curve totally uniformly at random.
So I'm going to collect points x and
y from points along this curve and just select them totally uniformly at random.
And now, given these points let's calculate covariance.
Well, the covariance between x and y is, if you recall
the expectation of x minus the mean of x times y minus the mean of y.
And if you evaluate this for the curve above you'll find that the answer is 0.
So you'll find that the covariance takes on a maximum value when the degree of
the polynomial is 1.
As they increase in degree, but
remain odd, the covariance gradually decreases slowly.
But for even degree polynomials the covariance always evaluates to 0.
Similarly, inter-tweet time and
mention distance are related, but they're not linearly related.
Now, this makes intuitive sense.
If someone you know calls out your name, you are likely to immediately respond.
In general, in addition, in real life relationships are not linear.